حريق بمتجر اسلحه يمتد الى مباني سكنيه في
منطقه الخرطوم اثنين اذا وهناك نداءات
استغاثه من سكان منطقه الخرطوم اثنين ونحن
طبعا منذ فتره نتابع هذه الصوره التي نشهد
فيها سوره الحريق والسنه الدخان والذهب
التي تتصاعد منه الحديث بالمعلومات عن
الحريق بمتجر اسلحه يمتد الى مباني سكنيه
في منطقه الخرطوم اثنين مع نداءات استغاثه
من سكان منطقه الخرطوم اثنين اذا بعد
اندلاع هذا الحريق بسبب الاشتباكات الوضع
قد يكون خطيرا
بسبب هذا الحريق خاصه وانه يلتهم متجرا
للاسلحه يعني نامل السلامه خاصه للموجودين
بجانبه او في محيطه على امل ان تتمكن بعض
الاطراف من الاستجابه لنداءات الاستغاثه
كي يعني تحقن الدماء في تلك المنطقه منعم
لسقوط قتلى او جرحى
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات